gravity exerts a force on every object
which is proportional to its mass the
amount by which it is proportional is
the value G or the acceleration due to
gravity on the surface of the earth G is
9.8 meters per second per second and
this is the rate that an object will
accelerate when it's in freefall now the
value of G will vary a little bit
depending on where you are mostly to do
with altitude and the value of 9.8 is an
average and it has actually been
measured quite precisely but today we're
going to throw precision out the window
and attempt to measure G using human
hair first let's talk about pendulums a
simple pendulum consists of a metal
sphere on a long thin string one period
of oscillation will be the time it takes
for this mass to go from say here
through one complete cycle and back to
where it started
we can work out the period T from this
formula here 2 pi times the square root
of L which is the length of our pendulum
over a G which is our acceleration due
to gravity
note that the period doesn't depend at
all upon the mass and just know that
this formula was derived using an
approximation that sine theta is equal
to theta so it's only valid for small
angles say less than about 15 degrees we
can rearrange this formula for G if we
know our length and our period
experimentally if you have a longer
length then you're going to have a
longer period which may reduce the
significance of areas when you're trying
to time the period so what better to use
as a length of the pendulum then some of
my hair now I am going to attach a mass
to the end to provide some tension force
that will allow it to oscillate I don't
personally drink but I found this nice
bottle opener which I think will be
appropriate now the big assumption here
is that my hair doesn't weigh very much
compared to the mass I'm going to put on
the end I'm assuming that the center of
mass of the pendulum is still going to
be in this middle spot on the end and
I'm also assuming that my hair stays a
constant length throughout which may not
be true in practice but I'm hoping we'll
be in ok
Meishan here to get my hair as close to
massless as possible I haven't included
all of it for the pendulum just a small
amount and I'm going to measure the
length of the pendulum as the distance
from the top of my hair tie down to
where I think the center of mass of this
metal part is I got some help measuring
the length and found it to be 90
centimeters with an uncertainty of two
centimeters then I released the hair at
an angle and timed five oscillations
this makes it easier to measure one
period by dividing the time by five
afterwards I repeated this part of the
experiment twice more and got an average
period of 1.9 seconds with an
uncertainty of five milliseconds putting
my values into the formula for G I get
GE equal to nine point eight plus or
minus zero point seven meters per second
squared and that's actually pretty good
especially synthesis far from a
high-tech science lab some of the
possible sources of error include
measuring the distance to the center of
mass assuming that my hair is massless
and also assuming that it travels out a
perfect 2d shape when in reality I think
it travels out a bit of an ellipse
there's also some uncertainty in the
measurement of the period of oscillation
if you wanted to make this experiment a
bit more accurate you could try using
various different values of owl for the
lengths of the pendulum and then finding
a line of best fit to find our value of
G but this was pretty alright for some
quick backyard physics now this video is
sponsored by brilliant org so if you
would like to have some fun with science
you can go to brilliant org slash
tibbie's and sign up for free they have
a course on gravitational physics so
that might be a great place to learn a
little bit more about the subject
discussed here the first 200 people to
go to that link can get 20% off an
annual premium subscription so I'd
recommend brilliant as a fun way to
learn more about some of the concepts
that I've discussed here if you enjoyed
this video then
please consider subscribing to my
channel and I'll see you next time
[Music]